[Music]
Silicon Valley is the new American dream
it's where companies are born and
millionaires are made like many of you I
was part of that dream before coming to
the GSB I was an executive at Cisco and
then went on to work for a
venture-backed startup what I'd like to
start with a much simpler dream the
dream of my grandparents I'm Sonia
Nicola they dreamt of running water
electricity and indoor plumbing things
they didn't have in their small village
in Mexico so they moved to the United
States in search of a better life where
they became migrant farm workers who
harvested the fields right here in
Silicon Valley before it became Google
Apple and Facebook but as you know the
field disappeared and when that happened
my family transitioned to role is to
provide the backbone of this valley the
people who clean your homes the people
who take out your trash and the people
who even take care of your children one
morning before school I got up really
early to go with my grandparents to work
I walked into the bathroom to help my
grandmother clean and I had never seen
such a mess before my grandmother saw
the look on my face and she explained
how important this job was but it would
allow us to put food on the table she
encouraged me to take pride in my work
to make that bathroom a sparkling clean
and I could make it my grandmother who
had a fourth-grade education taught me
that day to approach each and every task
with dignity and with grit in Silicon
Valley venture capitalists are in search
of the next billion dollar startup the
elusive unicorn will people from my
neighborhood we have a very different
definition of what a unicorn is I grew
up in East San Jose
about 20 miles south of here when I
think of home I think of my
grandmother's yellow kitchen I think of
the scent of her homemade tortillas and
I think of the sounds of money action
music as a little girl I love to play
outside and one day I meant to sneak out
when no one was looking and was happily
playing in the garden when I was a
corner of my eye I saw my grandmother
running towards me she scooped me into
her arms and like many Mexican
grandmothers scolded me in Spanish and
then made the sign of the Cross you see
my grandmother knew that although our
neighborhood was very beautiful it could
also be very dangerous
it meant walking home from school and
having a gun pulled on you it meant
being peer pressured to join a gang it
meant having a baby when you were a baby
my family wasn't immune to the sadly and
of my 20 cousins only 10 graduated from
high school and only three of us would
go on to graduate from college this
isn't unique to my family what is
happening to Latino families across the
country Latinos with college degrees
these are the unicorns in Silicon Valley
technology has been booming all around
us it's been creating tremendous
opportunity and wealth it's been
exciting and my family's been able to
take part of a little piece of it
my younger brother of equal is one of
the smartest guys I know it would really
frustrate me when I was stuck on my
physics homework assignment and he would
manage to solve it effortlessly he's the
kind of guy who loved to take things
apart and put them back together
he was a natural engineer my brother is
also a high school dropout and he became
a dad when he was seven
years old my brother was able to turn
his wife around to go back to school and
find a job working in manufacturing for
a local tech company because of that
opportunity he was able not only to
provide for his family but also for me
and one summer my brother gave me his
paychecks so that I could live in Paris
and study at the Sorbonne II that simple
act of generosity and love put me on a
different track it's the reason I'm here
with all of you but even with that
college degree my path to a career in
technology was very different than the
path that many of you took it was the
hustle I worked at three different
temporary agencies before I landed that
first job at Cisco and I will never
forget receiving that offer letter and
being so excited not only what it meant
for me but what it went for meant for my
family but the bubble burst the
manufacturing jobs went away my brother
lost to the job other people my family
lost their jobs my parents couldn't
afford their home anymore so they look
to me the one that's a good job to help
that entry-level salary at Cisco barely
covered a third of their mortgage so my
parents moved to central California back
to the fields where it all began
the Silicon Valley dream it was out of
reach for them while this area has been
growing at record pace communities like
East San Jose have been suffering one
setback after the other loss of jobs
loss of homes and lack of upward
mobility this isn't just my problem it's
our problem
Latinos represent one of the
fastest-growing groups in the country
this is expected to project a 1.5
trillion dollar opportunity think about
that I bet you didn't know that Latinos
have this beautiful entrepreneurial
spirit they start businesses at record
rate within my family alone there been
five businesses that have been started
so why if Latinos are starting
businesses at record rate why aren't we
able to capitalize on them
professor Jerry Porras here at the GSB
has been studying this very phenomenon
as part of the Stanford Latino
entrepreneurship initiative and one of
the things that he's discovered is
Latinos lack access to mentors as one of
the few people from my neighborhood who
had a career in technology I knew how
important it was to go back so I went to
the schools I attended and volunteered I
hosted events at local libraries I even
started a small scholarship fund through
this work I met Carlos Carlos had just
finished his freshman year at Harvard
when I asked Carlos Woods plans were for
the summer he looked at me and said that
he was going to work construction with
his dad when I asked Carlos have you
thought of an internship he said
Suchi I would love an internship but I
have no idea where to begin
Carlos was one of the lucky ones I one
of the leading institutions in this
country and yet even he was struggling
to navigate this business landscape I
knew how that felt but more importantly
I know how to help them find that
internship people like Carlos may not
have the polished resume they may not
have the pedigree but what they do have
is dignity grit and that entrepreneurial
spirit what they're missing is
opportunity so what I'd like to ask each
of you is that
you either are or will become leaders in
business in this valley and across the
world please look again at people from a
different path hire them mentor them
imagine the impact that all of us could
have on communities like East San Jose
if we add opportunity to the equation
[Applause]
[Music]